you obviously know Jim and James I know
I've met Jim once or twice we've hung
out a couple times you come to a couple
of shows this is very exciting to be oh
that's right because you're the
animation scene in a booth they put me
in a booth they do a movie he makes
sound because you could be in pajamas
doing your job oh yeah I was in
literally like an old school nightie
with a candle and a hat are you a golden
girl okay all three of the golden yeah
so we also work together and we never
met yes I was in a boot for that too yes
for hopes I did the voice thing - yeah
we never met I played an animated
version of myself singing about Hanukkah
so I played an animated version of
myself you know just seeing Christmas
yeah Christmas yeah yes yes and it was
very hard I went method oh really
playing myself was difficult um your mom
though is a teacher like mine and I love
my mother so much I love teachers and
your hardcore lover of your mama - right
yes I'd be very weird if this was the
moment I said I hate my mom I'm happy
we're doing this her mom is a teacher -
and you were like I love talking about
my mom and yet she's been a Bronx -
school teacher for 50 years
so you guys were you guys were very kind
you're likely my mom's name is Joan
Schwartz and one of the things I like is
there a picture about you and your mom
and I noticed that all the pictures of
me as a kid have my name on the shirt
they just didn't remember my they didn't
want to get confused yes so you're also
a published author that's crazy
published four books yeah what do you
publish the books
oh no I I yeah I four books but they
start off as these are books that it
would be like the cutest image called
grandma's dead breaking bad news and
baby animals oh we have grandma's dead
actually yep it's like the cutest
picture of an animal and it's supposed
to break it breaks bad news with a cute
animal so you could say in King babies
[Laughter]
many years ago so wait they're postcards
you can send someone to just cheer them
up yes so like that that way it like
softens the blow yeah are you in a car
Jim do you need to tell anyone anything
maybe not this one but you're not the
father I haven't seen this book in a
decade which makes it even more exciting
that we're looking it'd be better if it
said I'm not your father we've got
animals coming up are you an animal
person
I love animals yeah yeah yeah I very
much love animals I'm afraid of maybe
one or two but are you afraid of so I
can bring it out are you guys afraid of
animals at all who Durst cook yeah
I mean elephants I don't love snakes and
like big tarantula type I worked at the
Bronx Zoo for a summer I worked at the
Fort Worth Zoo real yes for a summer my
goodness tell me more I worked at the
petting zoo for a little bit too because
it made me feel like that cute and then
all you smell is crap yeah all you do is
look up yeah I love this making an
iguana okay look you don't know what an
iguana tastes like I do I'm good with my
vaccinations on what is it what is my
car to compare a little bit I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this